I'm looking for my sons oh they went on
a quest but don't worry I told him about
the map I told them about the gym I told
them about the curse congratulations on
this movie I love it so much it's just
these all the emotions one minute you're
laughing out loud another minute you're
crying yes
where does on word rank for you guys and
your incredible bodies of work as far as
emotional impact in the storytelling
goes it's pretty far up there if I'm
honest yeah I mean for me like growing
up admiring people in the film
industry's like I always wanted to be a
superhero spider-man specifically and I
was lucky enough to be given that
opportunity and then I always wanted to
be in a Pixar movie and here we are
today with my buddy Chris like it's like
I'm so lucky to be here and for it to be
such a great piece of work and something
that we're both equally so proud of it
just couldn't get any better really I'm
just pretty stoked to be here and I'm so
excited for people to see this movie
yeah this this is uh this is a film my
brother and I grew up watching a movie
called Radio Flyer and I have a have a
very close relationship with my older
brother Kali it's very much like barley
in this film and in many ways and every
time that movies on we'll text each
other say hey man Radio Flyers always
it's a tough night radio fires I just
love you so much man I just want you to
know I love you yeah and I feel like he
doesn't really know what this movie is
about and so I'm really excited to see
this movie with him and I think it's
gonna be kind of like that Radio Flyer
moment because it is it's a really
moving story about about brothers and
and in those movies just they moved me
because I am a little brother and I and
I you know just like you don't have to
be a boy to for the story of frozen to
resonate because it's between two
sisters I think anyone with a pulse is
gonna be moved by this story to me it's
profoundly moving because of my
relationship with my brother what
happens if if your brother doesn't get
it the film ends easy here's what's
gonna happen
he's not he's gonna totally get it and
then he's gonna turn to me and pretend
like he didn't get it rise to mess with
me yeah that's what my old business yeah
what was more emotional for you guys
Iron Man's debt or the ending of this
well I haven't seen the film yet and our
vendors Avengers don't even what what is
that film Iron Man's death for me was
super emotional because you know I have
a very very strong and close
relationship with Robin and also with
Ironman cuz I grew up watching those
films but I haven't seen this yet so I
can't really I can't really comment on
it I know what it was like when I
recorded it it was pretty emotional and
it didn't take me long to get to that
place of emotion it was very very
natural because I was there with Dan and
I was sort of telling his story and I
felt a responsibility to do justice to
him and his family but I don't know I
don't really know the answer that
question yet because I've seen it which
one's more emotional um they're both
pretty emotional but they're both
entertaining and I think it's a it's a
fun fighting making a motion palatable
and a movie is really about balance and
I think if you if you move forward with
just emotion it's exhausting and if you
move forward with just comedy it feels a
little empty and I think this is the
type of film that balances really nicely
and the jokes are tethered to a strong
emotional through-line and and the
emotion is tethered to amazing beautiful
scenery great jokes a bunch of really
like edge-of-your-seat adventure and so
it's really got a great balance of all
that but it'll make you laugh it'll make
you cry I can't wait for the world to
see I think you guys know Ron's gonna
give it I think a hundred percent
I wanted to ask you guys about a scene
in this movie that involves a cheese
puffs because it's such a funny visual
but at the same time barley is telling
this really heartbreaking story so why
is the juxtaposition of sadness and
humor so powerful because it's a
technique that Pixar just knocks out of
the park yeah I mean I think we try to
do it a lot because that's how life is
you know you're always having some it's
always when you're having some the
painful or emotional moment that the
most ridiculous annoying thing is
happening or the waiter comes up and
interrupts the name you want water I
think that's one of the things I like
about the fact that dad is just pants is
it's weird and it's awkward and it's a
little uncomfortable and but it's also
happening in this incredibly sweet way
and I think that that is what it's like
to be in family you know to have family
members to if the boys really want to
meet their father you're gonna meet the
good the bad the awkward the weird be
uncomfortable yeah we tried to do that
as much as we could in this film exactly
there's another scene in this movie it's
a very moving moment towards the end
where the moment is sort of told from a
distance through another character's
eyes what is the emotional impact and
significance of a choice like that yeah
I mean from the very early stages of
that moment and I appreciate that you're
not saying what it is I don't want to
spoil time I was like why did they do it
yeah from the very beginning we had it
that way and it's important sometimes
too I think you when you hold back on
something the audience can fill in a
moment emotionally if they don't have
all the information I think that's just
what I love about seeing films is when
I'm denied certain things and this
moment was really important that it be
seen this particular way and really
important that certain things not be
heard it's it's tough and I'm so happy
to work at a place like Pixar where
they're like yeah don't show that don't
let them hear
rather than you know oh but I want
everything I want all my cake
this is Pixar's first fantasy adventure
why this is Jean rah to tell this story
yeah I think we kind of needed this
genre to tell a story that involved
magic and involved these two brothers
going on a quest to bring their father
try to bring their father back for a day
and so it kind of needed to be it needed
to have magic and where do we see magic
but in fantasy and we wanted it to be a
modern because it is kind of a modern
story so it kind of just all snowballed
into a modern suburban fantasy world
yeah and and also is just tons of fun to
the world itself it is yeah I was like
the sky's the limit but yeah exactly my
last question for you guys is um Dan I
know you've lost your father at a young
age and that was inspiration for this
film I'm so sorry I'm what do you think
he would have thought of this film oh
boy you know I think he would have been
proud I for no other reason than he's my
dad and a parent but um no I think I
think he would have appreciated
hopefully not just the sentiment I feel
for him but seeing how how wonderfully
my mother and brother were in raising me
and helping me and you know seeing how
close we all were I think would mean a
lot to him
[Music]